mónica dr. Ajit Agarwal was an NHS
cardiologist for 40 years but he was
also a husband a dad and a granddad he
dedicated his life to medicine after
moving to the UK from India in his 20s
he died with kovat 19 aged 68 falling
ill just two days after retiring for his
daughters it was important he was
surrounded by his former colleagues this
is a handwritten note from the nurse who
took care of him he took the time to
write to us afterwards and she said I
wanted to let you know that he was not
on his own I held his hand that was
certainly no indication he was in any
pain
we used the patient profile to attempt
to him individually so I mean just the
just the fact that she must have an
incredibly busy job right now and took
the time to write that to us when we
couldn't be with him is really really
touching
the public admiration and respect felt
for health and care workers has been
clear to see and fear over the past ten
weeks but as the weekly applause starts
to fade and rainbows like these are
taken down some are asking whether we
need a lasting way to remember those
who've died that question has led to big
changes to a long-planned national
emergency services memorial renowned
sculptor Philip Jackson has
fundamentally changed his design to
incorporate the figure of a hospital
worker wearing full protective equipment
because of what has happened this
dreadful pandemic we decided that the
NHS side should be reinforced with the
secondary figure and so the ambulance
paramedic has now got a companion in the
nurse doctor figure the charity behind
the project is trying to raise three
million pounds to build it in central
London what we're seeing here is the
very best of our emergency services
brave men and women who are going out
putting their life on the line to save
you and me health unions have welcomed
plans
permanence recognition but warned the
priority now must be on protecting those
still risking their lives a sentiment
shared by Nikita and nimisha
I know what Dad would want and certainly
what I would like is to protect those
health care workers he was still on the
frontline that is the best way to honor
those who have died is to protect their
colleagues in their friends
KITT Bradshaw at Sky News in Suffolk